what's up with the what's up man what
are you an NBA young boy hanging out I
saw you going in on the internet today
what's going on what's going on man it's
just um
she sent the little tweet out so I just
responded man it's all good I was like I
just he said this ain't a meet and greet
um I come to business you know what I'm
saying ain't no meet and greet but at
the same time though you know Soldier
season now I'm just so happy to fall on
the same day so it's gonna be some some
competition you did what I'm saying but
at the end of the day man shout out
shout out young would you ever do a
record with a young boy
I would do a record with them uh yeah I
do a song on the main tripping yeah
yeah I feel like he puts out so many
albums that he probably puts out a lot
of albums on the same day as a lot of
artists she will she seems to be like
but anybody had nothing to do with him
though it started off with dirt you feel
what I'm saying I ain't even know he was
I didn't know young boy would drop
because he drops every other week so he
had nothing to do with him I announced
an album and then Dirk came and said he
was dropping on the same day then he
came and he said he was coming on drugs
he weren't really in it you feel me he
just he just got in it you did what I'm
saying because he wouldn't drop on the
same day it's dirt
and to be fair what you said was was was
the truth because I just had this moment
go viral I don't know if you saw where I
said the little Dirk
who has tons of plaques is extremely
successful
but I don't think he's had like a he
hasn't it's factual he hasn't had a top
10 Billboard single oh yeah on his own
yet he's been on Drake songs
but and there was no like slight to him
but you're right yeah man ain't no dis
manifest when you got the fastest fact
those guys don't gotta Crank that that's
a fake yeah I'm saying but at the end of
the day like man it's just competition
man y'all gonna get the album I saw this
season yeah those guys got other records
they got hellcats and trackhawks yeah
you know I'm saying but he moved it but
he precise back though so I ain't even
tripping do you think Dirk pushed the
album day back because of you
I don't know for sure why I saw you
thanked him or you shouted him out I
shot him out that's a real [__] [__]
like you know what I'm saying if you see
him on the internet tweaking obviously
it means something to me you think so
[__] you know I don't know 100 the
reason why he did it but he did it you
feel what I'm saying I saw [__] I
respect that I'm like man that's what
real [__] like and one of my partners
was dropping we dropping album on the
same thing he had a problem with it I
pushed my [__] back if I had if I had
the power to do it if it went too late
you know what I'm saying so what'd you
think of the new record did you listen
to his new record with J Cole I think
it's yeah I heard it it's different it
sounds different I think it's his best
record like in terms of like he might
get a Grammy he go get some radio
success like you know he's got some
crazy joints but I think that's a record
that's like
I could be like oh this is a single
single you know it's different for sure
for sure for sure
um tell me like man how do you go about
business ventures because I feel like
you're one of the more like
entrepreneurials just minded artists
we've had in the last 15 years I think
back to like yums and obviously you've
had shoes and you've you've had so many
things that we can point our finger to
and be like man soldier boy just you're
a hustler bro for real now for sure man
like that's how I've been since day one
like I always trying to get some money
man you know when it come to businesses
I just do stuff that I'm interested in
you know what I'm saying like video game
consoles clothing fashion I'm
um you know the black I got the soldier
blanks with signature shout out to
Signature my man to y'all you got
Soldier Bloods yes Soulja blunt raps you
know I'm saying black cherry flavor you
know what I'm saying signature smoke
brand my boy T.I he put that together
you know I'm saying shot big shout out
to him
um I just I just check I gotta get a bag
kill we gotta Get This Money Man by any
means necessary so
you know but we just doing we're doing
what we like though you feel me I rock
with the fashion Soulja Boy apparel I
we've spent all this money on Gucci we
spent all this money on Louis Vuitton
why we can't come out with our own
clothing line people support you feeling
I mean you had a very big clothing line
that's a fact and that's and that's what
it's all about I mean yeah I'm just
running rampant for a couple of years
yeah and it's like you like man I got I
got dreams too I got a vision too you
feel what I'm saying I'll be looking at
Gucci I'm looking at Louis how big it is
so I'm trying to be on that level you
feel me uh what have because I've last
time you were here we talked about the
video game console and I know you've had
some
you know a couple of complications with
rolling it out but but you have been
pretty transparent with your fans on
what's going on you know with with the
video game console what is going on with
the video game console we just did a
deal with Walmart man shout out to
Walmart we in all Walmarts you know
saying y'all go walmart.com go order
today so I was a boy game trdr Pocky
um we just added artificial intelligence
into AI you know what I'm saying so high
on the iPhone you can talk to Siri video
game console you could talk to it and
talk back to you you know what I'm
saying we'll talk back in your voice we
got that too you did because that would
be crazy so you know but um it was a
hard process you know but we here now
you feel me and I want to thank Walmart
for being the first big you know store
to support me you know what I'm saying
and we got we about to go into like uh
four more stores in the next couple
months that's big man I'll be on lookout
for that so it's like people buy the
console it comes pre-loaded you can get
whatever you want on their games Spotify
Apple music you know I'm saying it's a
whole whole platform me whatever you
want to get yeah y'all go get the album
the seasons play play the play the
social season album off the console you
could listen to it on the soldier what's
the name of the video game Soulja Boy
game soldier boy you can listen see
you're fully vertical at this point you
know what I'm saying yeah
how do you think artificial intelligence
uh is gonna change the rap game because
you know you I'm sure you've seen a lot
of these crazy uh
likes fake songs from artists yeah I
mean I just feel like you know I don't
know we gotta we got it's still new so
we gotta wait and see like I want
somebody to take someone random like
Adele and make an AI version of Adele
doing crank that that's hard
let's do it someone's gonna do that out
there because they're gonna see this
yeah somebody's gonna like it's possibly
the possibilities is endless man you
could do so much stuff but it's at the
end of the day it could be a good thing
it could be a bad thing you just gotta
wait and see how do you think it could
be bad
you know people use it in the wrong way
you know what I'm saying well you know
do you have a are you like pretty hip to
the uh like you know just the AI [__] in
general you have you have you [__]
around on chat gbt yet yeah I I've been
I'm in you know on through all the AIS
you dig what I'm saying chat GPT and all
that you know what did you what did you
converse with chat gbt about because
actually no artists who have asked
chat GPT what they should do for their
album rollout and like it'll write like
a 10 paragraph like album roll out now I
know no it's funny like
the [__] that I'd say I typed in a
couple things but the [__] that I typed
in it was like oh I can't help you with
that
sir that's it's an all-time and some
others out trying to figure out how to
hit okay okay where's the G-spot just
know that they have no answer for me
they said I can't help you with this sir
I said now close the app out they said
this is this this is you know we can't
we can't help you with this